[Music]
nobody pull hamstring the thing about
time travel I can't believe I made a
whole movie with this thing look cooler
doesn't feel cool but if it looks cool
as ice you have any idea what's coursing
through my veins right now Sun yawns yes
orange soda
we are getting the whole team aren't we
jock
[Music]
you have to do on here ten years of it
Oh clear which way oh you say something
I said I want to claw my eyes out but
unfortunately we're doing it good cuz I
already saw the awfulness will you focus
on focus this pretty place is about to
get are gonna fight real quick by a
bunch of freaking elves do you know you
know I sumo all these people who died so
this is a little bit difficult for me
okay so why don't you reach down deep
inside and try and find a small humanity
just committed they give me the things
you think I'm gonna come here you're
embarrassing all right which way you
don't know you used to freaking live
here for 1,500 years not forever
oh I think yeah maybe we are dead we are
so so dead
you